[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entre ses mains d'énormes pouvoirs de
nouveaux présidente de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi est la femme
politique la plus puissante des états
unis parfois admirer sont souvent
critiqués âgé de 78 ans nancy pelosi
fait partie du paysage politique
américain depuis des décennies pendant
huit ans john harris a été son chef de
cabinet
son plus proche collaborateur il la
décrit comme une politicienne presque
parfaite maîtrise des procédures
législatives campagne de financement
très efficace son ancienne patronne
connaît aussi les réalités et besoins
des élus avec qui elle doit négocier
chez nous des connaissances un flair qui
coule dans les veines de cette femme qui
a toujours évolué dans les coulisses du
monde politique
pourquoi nier les journalistes maxent
dallas a suivi sa carrière pendant vingt
ans il est l'auteur d'une biographie sur
nancy pelosi à bord témoin recettes
maison de la petite italie où elle a
grandi a longtemps été le centre du
pouvoir
une famille puissante dont le portrait
est fièrement affichés dans le
restaurant de germaneau fabiani encore
aujourd'hui des proches de m6 perd aussi
viennent manger ici la présidente de la
chambre elle même s'ils arrêtent à
l'occasion dans le quartier on se
souvient encore du règne de son père à
la mairie
dans la vraie carrière politique de
nancy pelosi a débuté à l'autre bout du
pays en californie mariée à un riche
financier de san francisco elle a fait
son entrée au congrès à la fin des
années 80 boss connu pour être exigeante
envers ses employés est parfois dur avec
ses collègues et adversaires la
démocrate a gravi les échelons jusqu'à
marquer l'histoire en 2007 elle est
devenue la première femme à présider la
chambre des représentants
[Musique]
un premier mandat de quatre ans
notamment marquée par l'adoption
difficile du projet d'assurance santé
obamacare que dans une période où
derrière les aptitudes politique
il ya aussi la figure controversée
kenneth weinstein républicains ne manque
pas de le noter donc il ya trois hommes
qui n'aiment vraiment détesté chez la
base républicains obama clinton appelle
aussi à preuve ces publicités
républicaine misant sur l'impopularité
nancy pelosi pour nuire au candidat
démocrate pendant les élections de mi
mandat
elle est vue comme un symbole de l'élite
du parti démocrate
la gauche caviar à quelqu'un de san
francisco bien aisé
et de quelques manières loin des
préoccupations de 2 des américains
moyens
c'est quelqu'un qui aime pas le
compromis trop progressiste pour les uns
pas assez pour les autres nancy pelosi a
même été contestée au sein de ses
propres rangs après la victoire
démocrate de novembre certains
réclamaient du sang neuf
[Applaudissements]
néanmoins choisi pour diriger de nouveau
les démocrates au congrès c'est elle qui
depuis un mois incarne l'opposition à
12h30 une adversaire expérimenté dont
dépend maintenant malgré lui le
président